le nettoyage est loin d'être terminé
deux semaines après les inondations
historiques et meurtrières d'Auckland
d'autres pluies diluviennes sont même
attendus dans la prochaine semaine il
s'agit d'une première crise à gérer pour
le nouveau Premier ministre
néo-zélandais
auparavant été ministre à tout faire
sous Jacqueline
sera difficile prévient ce politologue
le nouveau Premier ministre la lourde
tâche de succéder à jassimda Harden qui
a pris un peu tout le monde par surprise
en annonçant sa démission
devant le Parlement néo-zélandais des
citoyens tentaient de la voir une
dernière fois
et de la remercier pour sa gestion
empathique de plusieurs crises comme la
tuerie raciste de Chris Church en 2019
et le début de la pandémie de covid-19
vedette sur la scène politique mondiale
jasmineda Harden demeurer très populaire
à l'étranger la presse internationale
avait d'ailleurs souligné ses
réalisations après l'annonce de son
départ mais en Nouvelle-Zélande une
grande partie de l'électorat avait une
toute autre perception après près de 6
ans au pouvoir la cote de popularité de
Jasmine Harden avait fortement chuté
les mesures sanitaires jugées trop
strictes par une partie de la population
auront été le début de la fin pour elle
crois cet homme l'accumulation des
erreurs de communication par l'ancienne
Première ministre et l'augmentation du
coût de la vie de l'ordre de 7% ont
ajouté au frustrations
le nouveau Premier ministre Chris EPK
remanié le cabinet et énoncé de
nouvelles priorités notamment la baisse
de l'inflation à huit mois des
prochaines élections la Nouvelle-Zélande
tourne rapidement la page sur la période
jasminda
Wellington en Nouvelle-Zélande